caleb's with us in austin texas hi caleb
how are you
good better than i deserve how about you
guys just the same sir how can we help
figured out well i'm calling on behalf
of
my amazing wife her and her mom had a
falling out about
probably about three years ago and i'm
sorry
say it again how long ago probably about
three years ago three years ago
okay yeah and it's still pretty
uh pretty hectic um and so my
what does that mean what does hectic
mean uh
it's not it's not a good relationship um
we
so we had our son who just turned nine
months they met once
and our the kind of the rules we have is
not allowed at our house and my son's
our son's not allowed over there
and it's it's it's way heavy on my wife
um so what do you feel i need to draw
that's a hard boundary why'd you feel
the need to draw that boundary
it's it's uh it's just a cancerous
person
i guess to say be more specific you're
talking pretty vague be specific
something happened that said you cannot
do that there's a danger to your child
yeah uh well just the environment uh
her boyfriend is not uh
not the best man in the world um she's
just she's very negative she's always
heard our marriage would laugh and tell
people we're not gonna last when my wife
got pregnant
said uh you know that i wasn't gonna
stick around
okay and we had a miscarriage and she
just blew it off and
my wife just recently asked her to uh if
they could go to counseling and try and
fix it
and she was just like uh all things
about it
and it's just it's i mean it's just to
me
my kind of view is if if the thought of
being around someone stresses me now i
just don't even want to deal with that
that's easier said than when it's your
mom
and yeah and your
your wife has a picture in her head of
this new baby and her mom's a part of
that
and she had to draw boundaries for
whatever reason i still don't fully get
it but she had to draw some boundaries
that doesn't include her
so she's gonna agree i'm trying to
understand just as a guy i'll let john
talk a bit but but
so your mother-in-law's uh series of
offenses are that she's a jerk
uh yeah well i mean she's done something
other than has she done something other
than just been a jerk to your wife
uh no no like physical harm no but no i
mean
is her she just like nasty and kind of
mean
snarly snarling yeah and i mean there's
a lot of uh
ethical things that have gone on with
like uh
finances and stuff like that that i
don't want to air out right
like she stole from your wife uh
well from uh her father okay
she's just a person of no character
right yes
okay like so she only will talk to my
wife when her boyfriend's out of town
and then
when her boyfriend comes back she
doesn't respond to anything
so what's the challenge is your wife
just struggling with just putting a
period at the end of that relationship
and moving on
yeah it's it's yeah it eats her up
inside yeah
and that's where i'm calling and like
i'm just trying to
you know i guess the man of me is just
like well you know
so long and for her it's harder and i'm
just trying to figure out yeah it's her
mom yeah that's her mom
yeah you got to honor that don't go
don't get in the trap of talking bad
about her mom getting attracted
supporting her and loving her at some
point she's gonna have to make the
decision she's gonna have to put a peer
to the end of that sentence her mom's
never gonna do it with her
because if she would you wouldn't be in
the situation the first place so your
wife's gonna have to decide to grieve
this loss and then start creating a new
picture that's going to include
her baby you and whoever else but not
mom
and your wife can do that on her own
terms in her own time
and that's frustrating and annoying if
you're a husband who loves his wife and
doesn't want to see her hurt but any
time there's a separation from a mom
like this it's
just going to be hurt yeah it's going to
be hard
yeah especially a lot let me throw out
something um the secret to happiness
is low expectations
and so um if uh
if her mother had a
i'll just make up something i don't know
something where let's say she had
alzheimer's
okay and when people get alzheimer's
they generally either become much nicer
than they used to be or much meaner than
they used to be
um my mother-in-law got alzheimer's and
bless her soul she got nicer and um
uh and kept feeding the dog until the
dog got fit
fat i mean it was it was almost humorous
and so because she forgets she fed the
dog
yeah so if you had someone like that you
would not
we were never looked at sharon's mom
when she was going through that and said
we we lowered our expectations of her
because she was deficit
does that make sense yeah no that makes
more i mean
my expectations i don't mean to gain any
well yeah and i think your wife still
has
high mom expectations of a woman who
can't deliver
yeah and so if she lowered her
expectations and just said pretend like
mom has alzheimer's
and she's a little nutty because she's a
little nutty dude
the woman you just described is like
oscar the grouch
yeah and she's really not god she's
really not got her crap together
mentally this woman doesn't
but i can see the challenge between
someone with alzheimer's and saying this
person's
got i know but i'm saying if you if you
if you're i'm talking about
his wife if she said instead of hoping
mom is going to be all
supermom oh she's never going to be i
know instead said let's treat her as if
she's deficit because she is gotcha
if you and you just go oh that's just my
crazy mother this is just her mother
it's just my crazy mother that's just my
crazy mother yeah i mean and then you
don't
then you don't get all tore up about it
because she the reason my the girl's
getting all tore up about it she keeps
thinking mom's going to come through
she's got she's got this picture am i
wrong um
yeah but i think i think that i think
that
that having lower expectations isn't
going to make her feel good she's still
going to have to be
she's still going to have to grieve that
thing that mom's never gonna come
through like that i don't disagree with
that yeah
but i'm saying if every one of these
conversations it's like
my mom did it again well what did you
expect yeah
yeah yeah yeah if the rattlesnake's
gonna bite you right that's it
the stinking snake bites so don't be
when they start
you know when that little tail starts
wiggling and making that little noise
you just get back you know
caleb let me ask you this are you in a
place have you all backed yourselves
into a corner with an either or that was
a little bit over the top
or do you feel good about it um
and i'll ask you this i know a lot of
first-time parents who who make these
big declarations you can't come into my
home unless you've
you've showered in lysol and wash your
hands and by third kid you know the kids
walking in with a handful of dog do and
nobody cares right
have you all first kitted this situation
where you have
you've made these declarations yeah and
i don't know my mindset
is if you have to hide seeing my son
then why like
why why are we even gonna be around that
type of person
well i don't disagree with you yeah well
yeah it's the bottom line is there's a
lot of heartbreak for your wife
it's very hard for her um crazy mom's
just gonna be crazy
you're looking at it very like ah that's
what it is and
it's just it's it's her mom you can't
take that loose
that there's still that umbilical cord
in the spiritual world be gentle with
your grieving man i'll send you a copy
of henry cloud's book
called boundaries he's a friend of
john's and mine and it's a world-class
book on this subject
hold on i'll send you a copy of it